♪ ♪
>> Laura: 2018 IS COMING TO A
CLOSE, CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
SO WE THOUGHT WHAT BETTER TIME
THAN TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
MEDIA LOW LIGHTS FROM THE PAST
YEAR AND OUR FRIENDS AT GRADIENT
HELPED US OUT, TOO.
HERE WITH ME NOW TO TAKE US
THROUGH THE TAPE, FORMER
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE,
A HOST OF "MEDIA BUZZ" ALSO
RIGHT HERE ON FOX.
LET'S START WITH THE MEDIAS
WANTS WARM EMBRACE OF A MAN WHO
IS NOW NOT ON THE TOP OF THE
INVITE LIST.
LET'S WATCH.
>> STORMY DANIELS' LAWYER
MICHAEL AVENATTI JOINS US NOW.
>> JOINING NOW IS MICHAEL
AVENATTI.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI JOINS US
NOW.
>> JOINED ME NOW FROM
LOS ANGELES IS MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> WE WANT MORE OF THE SPOONING
COMMENTS.
>> HE WAS HARD TO BOOK.
>> HE WAS THE BELLE OF THE BALL,
UNTIL HE WASN'T.
SO THE MEDIA HAVE SEEN THIS
COMING?
>> THE NBC PUT THIS GUY ON
SEVERAL TIMES A DAY TO PEDDLE
HIS UNSUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS, BUT
THE WORST BY FAR WAS PUTTING
MICHAEL AVENATTI ON TO MAKE THE
CLAIMS OF THIS WOMAN WHO ACCUSED
KAVANAUGH --
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO SEE.
WE SEE THESE INTRODUCTIONS AND
IT'S LIKE, REALLY, TELL US MORE
ABOUT ALL THIS UNSUBSTANTIATED
GARBAGE.
THAT'S WHAT SHOULD GO DOWN ABOUT
THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
DISGUSTING.
ARE WE GOING TO THE NEXT ONE?
ALL RIGHT, HUCK WANTS TO
DESCRIBE THIS AS WELL.
I THINK MICHAEL AVENATTI IS ONE
OF THOSE FIGURES WHO WILL
OCCASIONALLY POP UP LIKE IF THEY
HAVE A CELEBRITY HOLLYWOOD
SQUARES MAY BE, HE WILL BE THE
LOWER RIGHT SQUARE OR SOMETHING.
BUT I DON'T SEE OF A MICHAEL
AVENATTI HAVING MUCH OF A ROLE
IN PUBLIC LIFE IN THE FUTURE.
>> I THINK HIS HISTORY IS UP
LIKE A ROCK AND DOWN LIKE A ROCK
AND A BACK UNDER THE ROCK FROM
WHENCE HE CRAWLED.
THAT'S THE END OF THE STORY ON
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> Laura: THE NUMBER TWO ON
OUR LIST INVOLVES SOME ACTUAL
DUMPSTER DIVING AS THEY TRY TO
FIND SOME DIRT TYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RUSSIA.
>> DID YOU LOOK THROUGH THE
TRASH THERE?
WHAT DID YOU FIND?
>> WE CAME HERE EXPECTING THIS
OFFICE TO BE EMPTY.
BUT IN FACT ALL DAY HERE, WE'VE
BEEN HERE THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE DAY, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
GOING IN AND OUT AND WE WENT
THROUGH THE TRASH CAN SEE WHAT
COULD FIND, NEW COMPUTERS ARE
BEING DELIVERED HERE.
>> SOMEHOW THE ACCENT MAKES IT
DIFFERENT.
>> NOT THAT BIG OF A DEAL, BUT
IT KIND OF SMELLS.
>> Laura: LITERALLY AND
FIGURATIVELY.
BUT THIS JUST TELLS YOU HOW LOW
THEY CAN GO.
GOING THROUGH THE GARBAGE NOW?
I GUESS YOU COULD DO THAT.
BUT, FOR WHAT?
>> I THOUGHT THEY WERE DOING A
TOUR OF THEIR NEWSROOM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU TYPICALLY SEE
WITH A LOT OF THESE NETWORKS.
ANYTHING, AND I MEAN ANYTHING.
THAT DOES SHOW THAT IF YOU ARE
WILLING TO GO THROUGH PEOPLE'S
TRASH HOPING TO GET SOMETHING
NEGATIVE ON CONSERVATIVES, YOU
ARE PRETTY DESPERATE.
AND THIS IS AN MEDIA THAT IS
PRETTY DESPERATE.
>> Laura: WHAT'S THE RATING
FOR THE MEDIA NOW?
THAT APPROVAL RATING USUALLY
HOVERS AROUND 20%.
OR DO PEOPLE RESPECT THEM?
>> IT'S UP TO 30 NOW.
THIS IS NOT MIGRATING.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, WE HAVE TO
CHECK THIS.
DO THAT GOOGLE SEARCH.
IS IT REALLY 30%?
>> I JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU,
HOWIE, THE FLU IS MORE POPULAR
THAN THE MEDIA RIGHT NOW.
>> WHILE IT IS ON A DOWNWARD
SPIRAL.
>> Laura: LET'S MOVE ON TO
NUMBER THREE, WHERE SOME CNN
HOSTED THE BEST THEY COULD TO
TEST THE LIMITS OF THE SEC.
>> IT'S THE CRAZIEST [BLEEP]
I'VE EVER HEARD.
>> [BLEEP] COUNTRY.
>> I'VE DEFINITELY [BLEEP].
>> SLIPPERS AND SLANT EYES.
I CALLED YOU [BLEEP] >> I CANNOT
[BLEEP] SPEAK OUT A LOT OF
[BLEEP].
>> DID YOU WEAR OUT THAT BEEPER?
THE ONE I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO
THOSE EDITS.
I GUESS PEOPLE ARE MORE
AUTHENTIC, LIVING THEIR TRUTH.
OUR PREVIOUS GUEST WHO WAS A WAR
HERO AND TRIPLE AMPUTEE, I DON'T
LIKE IT WHEN PEOPLE USE ON AIR,
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS OLD-FASHIONED
BUT, WE WANT TO NOT ON TV AS
MUCH IF WE CAN POSSIBLY NOT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS
OR NOT BUT THEY QUIT SERVING
SANDWICHES IN THE CNN CAFETERIA
AND NOW THEY JUST SELL SOAP FOR
PEOPLE TO EAT BECAUSE I GOT SO
POTTY MOUTH OVER THERE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHTER]
>> IN ONE OF THEM, SOMEONE
CALLED DONALD TRUMP A BS-SEVERAL
TIMES.
IT JUST GOES TO SHOW THAT ALL
ETHICS GO OUT THE WINDOW AND YOU
CAN CUT DOWN AND DIRTY AND
BECAUSE ALL YOU WANT.
>> WE HAVE AN ANCHOR WHO -- BUT
I MEAN IT'S JUST -- IT SHOWS
YOU -- AND I HATE THAT TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME HAS BECOME
SUCH A CLICHE BUT IF SOMETHING
IS BURROWED DEEP INTO THE PSYCHE
OF PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE NOT EVEN
ABLE TO HAVE FRIENDSHIPS WITH
PEOPLE WHOM THEY DISAGREE WITH,
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS WITH
AND OTHER MEDIA OUTLETS FOR
YEARS, I USED TO LIKE DON LEMON.
HE USED TO COME ON MY RADIO
SHOW, WE COULD DISAGREE, BUT NOW
THERE IS THIS BURROWED IN ANGER
AND RESENTMENT.
YOU ARE A HORRIBLE AWFUL ROTTEN
PERSON IF YOU EVER SAID ANYTHING
NICE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, AND
IT'S OOZING OUT OF THEIR PORES
WHICH IS VERY STRANGE.
THE LAST ONE ON OUR LIST TO
SOMEONE I JUST MENTIONED.
CNN'S DON LEMON DESCRIBING THE
BIGGEST TERROR THREAT FACING OUR
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP DEMONIZING
PEOPLE AND REALIZE THAT THE
BIGGEST TERROR THREAT IN THIS
COUNTRY IS WHITE MEN, MOST OF
THEM RADICALIZED TO THE RIGHT,
AND WE HAVE TO START DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
THERE IS NO TRAVEL BAN ON THEM.
THERE IS NO BAN -- WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT THAT?
THE ONE GOVERNOR HUCKABEE?
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE.
>> I'M GUILTY AS CHARGED, I AM
AN AMERICAN WHITE MAN AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT DON LEMON IS
GOING TO DO.
WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO, UP
DEPORT ME?
ARREST ME?
THIS IS THE HEIGHT OF IT.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU, IT'S NOT
JUST WHAT HE SAYS BUT THAT TONE
WHERE HE IS ATTEMPTING         A
WHERE HE IS ATTEMPTING         T
WHERE HE IS ATTEMPTING         M
WHERE HE IS ATTEMPTING         O
DILIGENTLY TO SOUND
AUTHORITATIVE.
THESE GUYS WHO SIT AND
PONTIFICATE NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
WITH SUCH A TONE OF SERIOUSNESS
AS IF THEY ARE PERSONALLY SAVING
THIS GREAT REPUBLIC --
>> Laura: THE PAIN.
I PAINTED TWO HAVE TO SAY THIS
OR I REGRET HAVING TO SAY THIS.
BEFORE WE GO, REMEMBER THIS AD
FROM CNN?
>> THIS IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
BANANAS.
SOMEWHERE BURIED WITHIN IT IS AN
APPLE.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT TRY TO TELL
YOU THAT THERE IS NO POINT IN
LOOKING FOR IT, BUT THERE IS
ONLY ONE WAY TO KNOW WHAT HAS
BEEN COVERED UP.
YOU START DIGGING.
>> Laura: MOVE OVER JAMES EARL
JONES.
I LIKE JAMES EARL JONES BETTER,
THIS IS CNN.
>> IT'S A KIND OF A FRUITCAKE AD
BUT THERE IS A LITTLE
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS THAT HAS
CREEPED INTO THESE ADS.
SOMEHOW DEMOCRACY WASN'T IN
DANGER -- >> Laura: THANK YOU